appareil comme dans la région rhône
alpes la réforme de l'assurance chômage
au centre des préoccupations plusieurs
manifestations ont eu lieu à lyon
villeurbanne notamment à l'appel du
collectif occupons 69,0 les personnes
occupant le théâtre national populaire
et l'opéra de lille depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant à percussion un
concert était au programme
selon la préfecture du rhône six cents
personnes ont répondu présent
2000 selon la cgt s'est mobilisé contre
la réforme de l'assurance chômage parce
qu'on ait beaucoup de précaires
énormément de précaires dans notre
progression
cette assurance est très fort mais elle
va mettre à mal beaucoup de beaucoup de
mon lien de gains pour beaucoup de gens
et
le moyen de
de gagner notre croûte entre deux entre
deux contrats précaires
[Musique]
qu'il pleuve qu'il vente qu'il neige on
est dehors et
on n'a aucune reconnaissance en fait que
ce soit au niveau humain et que ce soit
au niveau salarial
parce que pour donner un ordre d'idée
avec bac + 5
je suis payée 1300 europe où est ce que
je veux dire dans les cités de la
précarité il ya cette réforme qui est
absolument ignobles qui va être mise en
oeuvre à partir du 1er juillet qui a été
décidé par décret il ya deux semaines et
qui va rendre plus difficile l'accès à
l'allocation chômage qui va baisser les
allocations des travailleurs disent
continue donc dans ce mouvement là c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui a un coeur de
cible de ce qu'on revendique en sachant
qu'on veut pas s'arrêter là
parce que l'assurance chômage avant
cette réforme elle était déjà pas
satisfaisantes y avait six chômeurs sur
dix qui était pas indemnisé
l'indemnisation moyenne 7 et 9 100 euros
900 euros c'est bien en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté on vit pas avec ça